now Stephen Fry Stephen Fry this brings
us well I say sequel it's more of a
continuation yes of your best-selling
book of Greek mythology missiles this is
heroes it's out now and I mean the first
one was such a huge hit it was when
there was a big surprise to me I was
delighted but I've always loved Greek
myths and I actually started I found
myself a year and a half guys around a
table at someone's house and we were all
just talking about creation myths and
where they come from and I started
telling the story of the early Greek
gods the first ones and they all went
know about that you know where Zeus came
from because they're what everyone's
heard of certain names but they don't
necessarily know how they go together
and someone said well you should write
and now this one is carries on to the
errors yes this is more of the human
exactly by this time where it's getting
to be more human and they're clearing up
the world ridding it of monsters and so
on and because it's written in this very
kind of conversational way all the
dialogue is very kind of every day is
that you kind of trying to get the
reader to make connections between these
stories and our own lives sort of I mean
there's no question that for a lot of
people just a Greek word looks somehow
as if it belongs more to a schoolroom
than to a story because we think of
Greek as being an academic thing ancient
Greek well whereas of course to the
Greeks it wasn't and isn't now and I've
also wanted to create an atmosphere my
favorite Greek God in some ways is
Hestia perhaps the least well-known that
the firstborn of the Olympians who's the
goddess of the half and and the half
when you think about it all our
ancestors whatever our ethnicity Oh
our ancestors gathered around flames at
night to stay warm and to protect
themselves from animals and they told
stories about things over which they had
no control like where does they tell
their children where thunder comes from
and why there's fire coming out of the
mountain and everything you can't
understand and control you give a name a
god and so these gods were developed
personalities around the fire and and
now I think we can safely say we've lost
the half you know we don't eat round
tables anymore someone's got a
playstation in that room and they they
get a delivery of pizza into it and
someone else has got another they're
streaming things in another room
nobody gathers around and shares stories
anymore we've
focus just our half so I'm trying in the
books to recreate the relaxed feeling of
sitting around a fire listening to
stories which I think there's a primal
thing listening them together and so
that's that's to do with arson lots of
heroes but does Queen atlanna appear
well I should say of course happily that
I'm using the word here as a
gender-neutral word
there's Atalanta from one of my favorite
hearers yes you've linked Queen atlanna
not my film well as film yeah yeah um
James ones film yeah well I guess that's
advantage well the Queen atlanna is
queen of Atlantis well it's a good
example of how these things kind of go
into our languages was a Titan who
fought in the war of the Titans against
the gods and his punishment because he
was the most severe enemy of Zeus and
the Olympians was to hold up the sky
yeah and he that image of him bulging
like a Bulgarian weightlifter holding up
the sky was used by early mappers of the
world and they called those maps atlases
after him the picture and so it's all
connected so your Atalanta would
presumably Atlantis is that their name
planner Nicole I can't tell you how
smart what's your IQ know is it's in the
reasonable
nothing
[Applause]
[Music]